qui va faire la vaisselle étendre le
linge ou passez l'aspirateur
les questions posées dans cette vidéo
dans le cadre du projet aime ton couple
dans ce cas la sensibilisation porte sur
le partage des tâches ménagères avec
comme outil des dessins humoristiques et
généralement juste illustrait une
situation qu'elle va l'écrire et la
faire
vous voir de manière humoristique le but
c'est de faire moins de bulles parce que
s'il ya trop de bulles ça se voit pas
dans les vidéos ou c'est pas très
claires et vite c'est à dire quelque
chose de simple qui parle à tous à
l'initiative du projet l'association
yvelinoise un avenir à deux une
vingtaine de personnes participent à
sensibiliser au bien-être de la vie en
couple à travers différents témoignages
par exemple nous avons parlé de la
dispute de reuze maman s'est disputé la
coupe et c'est pas grave de ces 10 pt
les tout savoir comment se discute et on
a traité un thème sur la sexualité
comment parler de fait notre sexualité
en couple la caisse d'allocations
familiales participe au financement du
projet de son côté le conseil
départemental des yvelines apporte une
subvention de 45 mille euros ça se passe
complètement dans l'objectif du conseil
départemental qui est de travail sur la
prévention
la preuve en est plus précoce possible
notamment sera question de la protection
de l'enfant se fait plus largement de la
relation parent enfant est encore plus
de façon précoce sur la relation de
parent apparent prévenir les séparations
et assurer le bien-être des familles
l'association un avenir à deux espèrent
une fréquentation de 500 visiteurs par
jour sur le site internet